details of the duke of edinburgh's
funeral have just been released
the funeral will be taking place here at
windsor castle
next saturday at 3 p.m there will be no
public access
or public processions the event will be
within the current covert guidelines but
still
very much reflect the personal wishes of
the duke
there will be a national minute silence
at 3 p.m
and his children and grandchildren
grandchildren
are expected to attend including the
duke of sussex but megan
who is expecting her second child will
not because of doctor's advice
well in the procession from the castle
tucson george's chapel the duke's coffin
will be moved
inside a specially modified land rover
well in a moment we'll be getting
reaction from our royal commentator
alistair bruce and from our u.s
correspondent craig milam who's in los
angeles near the home
of the duke and duchess of sussex but
first
let's bring in our royal correspondent
rhiannon mills who joins me here and
rhiannon in the last few moments then
we're able to confirm that prince
philip's funeral will be taking place
just through
that archway there in saint george's
chapel and it will indeed
be a ceremonial funeral albeit paired
back
that's right we were told yesterday that
her majesty the queen was
taking a final look at the plans for the
duke of edinburgh's funeral
and a large part of that was due to the
fact that they are now dealing
with the coveted restrictions and having
to rearrange some of the plans to make
sure that all of the plans that they've
had in place for a number of years
were still within the restrictions that
the rest of the country
are having to abide by um at the moment
but as you said we have now got official
confirmation that the funeral
will take place next saturday at three
o'clock
we also know that it will be a full
ceremonial royal funeral
it won't be a state funeral that is of
course as we anticipated we know that
prince philip never wanted a fuss it
could have been the fact that the queen
could have allowed him to have a state
funeral which is usually
afforded to monarchs but the queen could
have allowed that to happen but
certainly
the duke did not want that to happen but
of course because of covid it means that
all of the ceremony and
the military involvement has had to be
significantly scaled back
because in the past we would have
anticipated that we would have seen a
lot more ceremonial taking place
in the centre of london and then
potentially his coffin being transferred
back here to windsor instead
we're going to see all of the funeral
and the procession around it
take place within the grounds here at
windsor castle instead
so as i said three o'clock uh next week
next saturday the ceremony will take
place we know there will be
no public access there will be no public
processions
and the public will be encouraged
however to take part
in a national minute of silence which
will take place
at three o'clock as procession and makes
its way
inside of saint george's chapel um we're
also being told that the
plans that are now in place are very
much still
in accordance with what the duke himself
would have wanted
and there is one particularly lovely
touch within there the fact that his
coffin
as part of the procession is going to be
moved from the state entrance
at windsor castle to st george's chapel
on the back of a specially
modified land rover and within the
briefing that we've just been given we
were told that actually
prince philip himself took a great deal
of interest
um in that vehicle and helped to design
it himself so i think that is
a wonderful touch for for a man who was
so interested in things like technology
knowing what we do about the duke of
edinburgh and how he had a no-nonsense
approach to life one wonders if given
the covert restrictions in fact that
this paired back funeral may
indeed have been perhaps more to his
taste even than the ceremonial
uh funeral that he had indeed approved
tell us a little bit about who will be
attending because of course
family numbers strictly restricted
whilst we are going through the pandemic
yes so i think for the royal family as
right throughout the pandemic they've
shown that they've wanted to stick
within the covert guidelines and
to set the example to the rest of the
country and i think also very conscious
that
many people have lost loved ones during
the last year
and so when it comes to the funeral they
will stick to the guidelines there will
only be
30 people inside the chapel
when it comes to the congregation there
will of course be other members of
clergy
and also the bearer party will be on top
of that 30.
we're told to anticipate that that will
include of course her majesty the queen
um the duke's children and grandchildren
but
at the moment we're still waiting for
full confirmation of exactly who's going
to be within that congregation but yes
one thing that i think
many people have been wondering and that
is whether the duke of sussex would make
his way over from america
it has been confirmed in the last few
moments that yes prince harry will be
making his way
um here for the funeral however megan
who we know is heavily pregnant with her
second child has been advised by doctors
not to make that journey and so we wait
till later in the week to find out a few
more details about
who's going to be in that congregation
and who may
carry out any readings when it comes to
songs that may be
sung those kind of details were
anticipated we will get
later on in the week